[Music]
Republican Governor Joe Lombardo pitched
assembly Bill 330 to lawmakers I believe
that ab16 168 while well intended has
led to this increase in dangerous
situations in schools across the state
it handcuffs teachers and administrators
his bill would meet restorative justice
in Nevada schools an option not a
requirement as it is now it also allows
for expelling students who assault staff
or sell drugs in the temporary removal
of a problem student teachers and
administrators who support Lombardo's
Bill spoke in Carson City the pushback
on restorative justice came after
several high-profile incidents in CCSD
including one of a student who wrote
poorly sexually assaulted a teacher at
El Dorado High School the culture in
these schools has gotten out of hand in
terms of student behavior and what we
have seen is an escalation of violence
some people also share their opposition
to the bill and to changing the current
restorative justice framework where
these expelled elementary students go
where will they go I did not hear an
answer because there are no alternative
schools they will go to their homes this
proposed law would give districts the
power to expose students younger than
the age of 11 and it also applies to
Charter and university schools Joshua
peguero 8 news now I get this according
to the governor there's been a 46
percent increase in violence and sexual
assault reported at CCSD schools since
2019. Denise